PlayStation Plus is required to play
your ps4 games online but it's also a
great way to get free games each month
but US and Canadian subscribers will
soon be paying a little more for the
service in the States the 12 month plan
is increasing to 60 bucks and the
three-month plan is increasing at 25
bucks a single month will still cost you
10 in Canada the 12 month plan is rising
two seventy dollars and the three-month
plan is rising at thirty dollars a
single month is also moving up to 12 to
quote the PlayStation Blog the new
pricing reflects the current market
conditions while enabling us to continue
providing exceptional value to our
members as a member you will continue to
enjoy the benefits and features that
enable shared experiences such as online
multiplayer free games and exclusive
discounts this is the first time PS plus
prices have increased in the US and
canada since the service launched in
2010 don't forget that access to PS Plus
games does go away when a subscription
lapses so your library will shrink if
you don't accept the new pricing to keep
up with all the latest from PlayStation
you're already in the right place
you